una fábrica tiene máquinas que producen
juguetes los cuales se empacan por los
trabajadores de la fábrica un día cada
máquina produce 14 juguetes y cada
trabajador empaca 2 juguetes por lo que
un total de 40 juguetes permanecen sin
empacar además el número de trabajadores
ese día era 8 menos que 7 veces el
número de máquinas cuántas máquinas y
trabajadores había
este es un muy buen problema y los
invito a qué pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta
lo primero que vamos a hacer es definir
algunas variables digamos que m
es el número de máquinas número de
máquinas
y digamos que w
es el número de trabajadores
número de trabajadores
trabajadores
es lo que nos dice el enunciado bueno
nos dicen que en un día una máquina
produce 14 juguetes así que cada máquina
produce 14 juguetes el número total de
juguetes va a ser el número de máquinas
m por lo que produce cada máquina 14
juguetes así que tenemos 14 por m y
estos son los juguetes que se producen
dulce
y cuántos juguetes se van a empacar
bueno si nos dicen que cada trabajador
va a empacar dos juguetes pues el total
de juguetes empacados va a ser igual a
el número de trabajadores w
por el número de juguetes que pueden
pagar cada 12
estos son los juguetes empacados
empacados
y nos dicen que 40 juguetes permanecen
sin empatar entonces aquí vamos a tener
40 que van a ser juguetes producidos
pero no empacados
producidos
no empacados
como relacionamos a los juguetes
producidos con los no empacados pues si
tomamos el total de los juguetes
producidos y les restamos el número de
juguetes empacados nos va a quedar el
número de los juguetes producidos pero
no empacados y de esta manera ya
encontramos una ecuación lineal que
relaciona a mwv pero una ecuación lineal
no nos es suficiente cuando tenemos dos
incógnitas sin embargo aquí tenemos otra
restricción nos dicen que el número de
trabajadores ese día era 8 menos que 7
veces el número de máquinas vamos a
escribirlo por acá el número de
trabajadores w ese día era igual a 8
menos que 7 veces el número de máquinas
o 7 veces el número de máquinas 7m y a
esto le restamos 8 y ahora sí tenemos
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y si
todo sale bien podremos encontrar los
valores de w
y hay muchas formas de resolver esto y
ya que tenemos esta ecuación en términos
de w w es igual a esto pues podemos
tomarla y sustituirla en la w de acá o
mejor dicho podemos tomar este 7 m menos
8 y esto sustituirlo en lugar de esta
doble o de manera que con esta
sustitución vamos a tener los valores de
mwv que satisfagan a ambas ecuaciones
así que esto nos queda 14 m
14 m - 2 que multiplica a w pero
quedamos que está w la vamos a sustituir
por 7 m menos 8 así que esto es 2 por 7
m
-8 y esto es igual a 40 ahora todo lo
que tenemos que hacer son operaciones
algebraicas nos quedan 14 m
- y esto lo voy a hacer en un color
neutro menos 2 por 7 m pues 2 por 7 va a
ser 14 14 m
y menos 2 x menos 8 va a ser igual a más
16 y todo esto es igual a 40
seguimos simplificando 14m menos 14 m es
igual a 0 y nos quedaría 16 igual a 40
pero esto en la vida se va a cumplir 16
jamás va a ser igual a 40 así que no
importa qué valor tenga mwv esto es
falso es más aquí ya ni están ni la m ni
la w así que esto de aquí es imposible
es imposible y como esto es imposible
pues este sistema de ecuaciones no tiene
solución no existe ningún valor para m y
para w que cumpla con las restricciones
que nos han puesto aquí así que esto no
tiene solución
no tiene solución
solución